what advice could you give to to a
beginning poker players or actually at
every level how to get better how to
improve how to improve their game
obviously as you said it's easiest to
get better in the beginning but what
advice would you give how to get better
so one of the ways I mean I think way
back to how I started right and there's
so many resources and tools available
right now to analyze hands but when you
play right and you find yourself in a
situation or a hand that you're not
really sure about not because you had
aces and went all in and you lost like
that's not interesting but an
interesting situation where you're not
sure what you did jot that jot the hand
down write it out and then either a you
know use some of the tools whether it's
the solvers if you're you know Advanced
enough or ask your group you know like
have a couple friends at your level and
talk through the different decisions and
start to learn that way right because
those mistakes that you make or those
tough those tough hands that's where the
real learning comes from like so that
next so basically if you're because
you're going to be in similar scenarios
in poker you're rarely going to have the
identical situation but you'll have
situations that are similar you know you
raised with Ace King someone three bet
another guy goes all in okay well what
do I do in that spot you know it's
you're going to have similar situations
in the future as well so figuring that
out the more you can do that you chop
away at um you know different
strategical mistakes you know you you
used to make that you no longer make are
there resources like your master classes
really is great are there books
so there was a guy named Michael Acevedo
this is my again for a little bit more
advanced players but it's a book called
uh modern poker Theory I think it's
called
um which sort of explains Game Theory
right to the novice right so it's it's a
little bit I think if you're new to
Poker it's probably Above the Rim for
you but once you start to get a little
better and you want to understand how to
do it it's probably a good resource for
as far as books and there's also like
tons of people who stream poker
professional players and then you can
get in there and you get in on the chat
and you start talking you ask them you
see people you know explaining their
thought process and things like that
there's so many free resources and of
course my master class I think does a
good job of sort of compartmentalizing
like you know
how to attack it on a deeper level and
you know we get it I try to get into
what's funny when I did the Master Class
I asked them I was like well you know
how high-end do you want this in terms
of Poker and they're like we want really
really high end and I was like oh are
you sure then I started to explain
really really highly like okay well
maybe the one below that
right
try to explain really complex
um
you know theory in a more palatable way
in English if you will because some of
these kids you hear them talk and you'll
be like huh but you also which is really
nice give uh example hands that really
illustrate the point which is really
nice
um you also wrote a book I think 10
years ago power holding strategy
it's interesting to think how much of
the stuff in that book still applies how
much doesn't listen I still think the
book holds up to a certain degree
obviously like you know it isn't optimal
because there's like a more advanced
strategies and if you played that way
people will figure out a way to exploit
you but if you're like an average player
playing an average buy-ins like that's
sort of what I coined like small ball
approach absolutely will work you know
at the highest level you have to add
much more a lot more bluffing but
overall I think it's still you know for
the most part there's a lot of really
especially with tournaments there's a
lot of really good principles in the
book